economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio luis méndez luis muy buenas
noches y vamos a comenzar hablando de
esa gira que está realizando el
presidente de argentina alberto
fernández por diferentes países de
europa así de santiago el día de hoy el
jefe de la casa rosada- visitó francia e
italia y en estos encuentros que entre
otras cosas recibió el respaldo del
presidente en manuel mccrone para
alcanzar una renegociación de deuda con
el fondo monetario internacional
argentina previo a la pandemia afrontaba
una compleja situación económica debido
a una deuda que cerró en el año 2019 por
el orden de los 323 mil millones de
dólares alrededor de 44 mil millones de
dólares de la deuda corresponde a un
préstamo standby que recibió el país de
parte del fondo monetario internacional
en el año 2018 bajo la administración
del entonces presidente mauricio macri
argentina debe comenzar a pagar dicho
préstamo este año y ya en marzo el
presidente fernández admitió que la
deuda era demasiado pesada para el país
en 2020 la deuda cerró en 335 mil 582
millones
dólares y entre los acreedores se
encuentra también el club de parís
organismo al que la nación le dé un
préstamo por 2.800 millones de dólares
pero escuchemos lo que dijo el
presidente fernández
llegado hasta aquí y también para
abordar los problemas que tiene
argentina
problemas que tienen que ver con poner
en orden sus cuentas con los organismos
internacionales de crédito puntualmente
con el club de parís y con el fondo
monetario internacional luís y sigue la
tensa situación en eeuu por la falta de
combustible en algunos estados así es
una situación que surge tras un gran
ataque cibernético al oleoducto colonial
pipeline pero los operadores informaron
el día de hoy que volvió a entrar en
servicio de acuerdo con informaciones
del diario 'new york times'
pese a ello los temores por el
desabastecimiento y el costo del
combustible provocaron una alta demanda
que generó largas filas especialmente
las estaciones de servicio de la costa
este del país de acuerdo con la agencia
de noticias reuters que cita a la
asociación estadounidense del automóvil
el precio del galón se ubicó en tres
dólares el más alto desde el año 2014
ante el panorama yo pagué anunció
algunas medidas escuchemos creo que van
a escuchar buenas noticias en las
próximas 24 horas y creo que todo estará
bajo control
mientras tanto facilite el levantamiento
de algunas restricciones sobre el
transporte de combustible así como
acceso a las fuerzas armadas de eeuu que
proporcionan combustible y vehículos
para llevarlo a lugares donde más se
necesita
berlín
otro tema que también influyó en eeuu
fue el de la inflación que se registró
en 4.2 por ciento en el mes de abril si
lo comparamos con el mismo período del
año 2020 el dato estuvo por encima de
las estimaciones de los analistas
louis a pesar de la pandemia con el 19
el comercio de china con algunos países
ha crecido así lo voy a conocer un
reporte del medio chino 'global times'
que refiere a un aumento en el
intercambio comercial de ese país con
países de centro y el este de europa
según la publicación que cita el
ministro a tanto de comercio red holding
el intercambio comercial entre china y
esos países se elevó un 52 por ciento
interanual durante el primer trimestre a
30 mil 130 millones de dólares el dato
se presenta de acuerdo con el medio
superior al promedio de crecimiento
comercial de china en este mismo período
adicionalmente el crecimiento sostenido
entre 2012 y 2020 entre china y 17
países del centro y este europa se
presenta por encima del intercambio
comercial entre china y la unión europea
es buenas noticias para la empresa
amazon
y es que la justicia europea falló a su
favor en un caso de presuntos beneficios
fiscales el caso data de 2017 cuando
tras una investigación la comisión
europea decidió que el luxemburgo
debería cobrar a amazon la cantidad de
250 millones de euros que había dejado
de percibir la multinacional indicadores
de las jornadas ya no habíamos
adelantado cayeron las bolsas en estados
unidos al superar las temas de inflación
es las estimaciones previstas por los
analistas mientras tanto en europa hubo
cierres con algo de ganancia no así en
el mercado japonés en américa latina las
bolsas lamentablemente cerraron en rojo
gracias al revés por esta actualización
de la economía aquí en fredes 24 buenas
noches para todos
[Música]